[Music]
do you guys cheat on your partners with
food oh my god I heard about this
absolutely course how does that work
you sit in the car you enjoy your sit
before you go home abso-fucking-lutely
then they don't know that you went there
and didn't ask them if they wanted is
that what cheating for food is like you
know they like it and then so you just
get it but then you know you don't want
to share so you're on a diet
um and I'm like [ __ ] man he's on a diet
and feel [ __ ] charged [ __ ] I'm gonna
just eat this hamburger and then when we
talk about food be like what you know I
could and you could do whatever you want
don't take it personal I am just guy if
you get a person let's not touch that so
many times before well here's the thing
they know it for me sometimes it's like
I'm just hungry and I'm gonna get this
before I go home because I know if I go
home and she's hungry if I ask her what
she wants she doesn't know right right
yeah we gotta spend 30 45 minutes on me
don't wind up options denying [ __ ] you
have to picture how about in and out no
how about me no how about no Spiker pin
then you say okay what do you want why I
don't know how do you not know I gave
you 30 options you shot all that [ __ ]
down it absolutely is my problem
but guess what this is why I [ __ ] eat
in the car here there's no default you
and your wife like one thing and it's
pretty easy like me more love Thai food
so it's like you're on typhoons and
she's like yeah yeah well my default
will always be pizza
I can always [ __ ] go for pizza my
wife doesn't like it if she does like he
says he doesn't like she likes Papa
John's it's like pizza what the funny
that's the [ __ ] blandest pizza every
cool Papa John's [ __ ] gourmet pizzas
no it's not man but they got the sauce
the garlic sauce pepper cheese
better ingredients B land a pizza you
know leave just no seasoning
no one goes the top national giant is
the widest piece of you can go that's
the widest beat up the white lily white
there is no flavor no seasoning in a
hurry any pop attack season I'm in
kitchen there's no oregano
there's no say there's no nothing you
can put it on land as pizza it should
come seize enjoy the races of the pizza
then there's a town of Mexican and which
was the Black Watch was hell yeah okay
okay
the Italian I will have you know who's
there time yeah I think you know as a
white dog yeah well guess what you won't
find out on my account to here as a
representative the white race right now
yes I would like to say that California
Pizza Kitchen is actually the white
pizza that's the most gentrified pretty
white though no [ __ ] pizza this is
what I mean by this is what white is
like would be to like that's like that's
like saying all right a wipers gonna
open a chicken spot and in it in any
neighborhood right okay you would not
expect it to be season will right why
never have Louisiana chickens I've been
in my white friends apartments and there
are no season you know what they call
seasoning salt and A's so whoa those
people it just mayonnaise and salt you
won't find the lorries there you won't
find any seasoned salt you won't find
any Liberty Bell that will find crack
crack fresh cracked black pepper bird oh
babe I see yes I've heard of all baked
people why do people like going to old
Bay's know why people like Old Bay
seasoning as well between southern white
and like west coast yeah absolutely
cause white likes like they like to eat
like spinach yeah yes back to my back to
my description so if a wiper doesn't
open the chicken spot in any
neighborhood right I would ever white
person open a chicken spot in like the
blackest part of Oakland their gland and
it just like yeah I'm gonna open the
chicken spot and then we're gonna also
open up the Starbucks right here that
would be a gentrified rest of us they
are trying to justify that area and
that's what CPK is with the cardiff all
alone right that's the white whale you
see the [ __ ] where and that's a linen
suit here playing front of Himalayas
drafted the colonel I didn't know we
didn't have the Cardinal it for the
south come on where you from originally
I'm from Indiana Virginia oh [ __ ] now
you ain't had the colonel what you
talking about half cap see up that horse
yeah we're deer Queens man we got we
exactly a dairy keep you at the Dairy
Queen for your chicken that holds a lot
about where your funds no we went to
Derek screen further sandwiches have a
lot about waiting from
nobody's ever liked oh [ __ ] I got a
hankering for a burger from Dairy Queen
said no whatever I said sandwiches well
that includes my surprise that Dairy
Queen may be surprised I will get back
to you and your girl right so you eat in
the car to avoid having to deal with
this whole kind of eye contact
absolutely yeah and also the judgment do
you hide things do you hide food inside
your home my favorite cereal in like a
special case over my daughter cuz this
let her full we eat up all my cereal I
literally buy her the same chips I'll
buy me and she would eat my chest first
wow she's a so better not be white chips
you know sometimes food is what
delicious anymore after you buy it if
he's never bought something put it in
the fridge and you go it doesn't look
that delicious anymore because I already
buy it
dude that's me all the time I always
keep like candy like Reese's peanut
butter cups in my purse or something cuz
I [ __ ] love them but the fact that I
have them in my purse and I bought them
it's just not that that's a good
deterrent though it's better when it's
stolen or given to you I lost the most
weight in my life I lost 60 pounds
loading my freezer with all my favorite
ice cream that I wanted to eat and
because I knew
had it no more you've been right Jojo no
that is crazy because that has never
happened to me I've never had ice cream
in the freezer like yeah I'm not gonna
test same I will [ __ ] butter pecan ice
cream gonna send me I will put bottom of
the cart man we will go down no gays
being played with butter pecan ice cream
not even kidding us my favorite ice
cream I love it yes then I would talk to
[ __ ] one what's that one from the
drugstore [ __ ] Jesus
the Blue Bell another [ __ ] maybe it's
the 30s oh good they have the
cylindrical it's a yellow yeah anyway so
there was a study conducted by one poll
where they 2,000 Americans and
relationships and they found that 71%
make unhealthy choices behind their
partners back Wow so many people are
[ __ ] frauds to their to their
significant others dude I used to drive
my chick to the airport and then go go
get [ __ ] Taco Bell afterward well it's
like a little like like a celebration do
I get to do whatever I want tonight I
get it's a freebie yeah why you're not
allowed to get Taco Bell well no that
was like that was that was not judgment
would be there yet a judgment that's
really what it is that's what it comes
down to like the judge cuz i would like
i said i've done some fashion yeah like
and like even when i'm eating in the car
i take my shirt off it gets intimate
what I'm eating Oh pants are on that's
good huh I put on slow jazz I [ __ ]
take my clothes off yeah all of them he
said he takes his shirt off you said
clothes take away clothes on for you
he's at home I would come out in the car
I do mind in the car yeah no I didn't
lights and everything
mmm-hmm that was spin that no that's
evidence that's what a lot of guys [ __ ]
up they just do [ __ ] without thoughts
like I'm thinking three steps ahead I
paid with cash yeah cuz my wife has
found receipts in the trash can before
was like so you went to talk about I was
like I bought something for home like
you're not allowed no she's not allowed
to go to Taco Bell when I what I'm
saying what I'm verbally saying I gotta
eat better I gotta I gotta switch it up
and I gotta get healthy and stuff like
that and if she finds [ __ ] Taco Bell
two days later she like so this is this
is
well she finds a receipt and she's like
to hear did you go to Papa John's no
room with that ever [ __ ] that's not my
pizza to hear I will never ever ever eat
Papa John's
what if you're so [ __ ] hungry I will
die I will die know what I like about
Papa John's is when it's Jonah to give a
[ __ ] but when for some reason when they
deliver it the cheese is never milky
that's not actually so sad
never seen a Papa John's commercial
where like the cheese is coming like
they don't do that oh we got a peanut
they do that he's a hub and appease us
do that
yeah but Papa John's because it's the
blandest [ __ ] Pete take the team they
[ __ ] your honor tiene a name Peter I get
it they cook it in the easy-bake oven I
so that's just barely warm it's a 40
watt bulb that they're cooking this
[ __ ] pizza with look I don't think it
personally you cuz not going after my
CPK do you like did you say pizza even
apologize Little Caesars Papa John's
Domino's Pizza
Little Caesars five dollars baby [ __ ]
pizzas literally Little Caesars slogan
is money it's five dollars like that's
the hole so I saw 6-8 commercials with
that and I was like you can't be mad at
that yeah there's a white girl that said
Evan 11 pizza no so are you serious it's
horrible
bro bring it bring it right it listen
you have to get it here's the thing what
let's have a bagel boy you have to get
it fresh you have to get that whole
pizza cuz if you do the slices they've
been there all day but if you get a
whole pizza yeah
and [ __ ] they cook this [ __ ] in like
four minutes they slice it right in
front of you now that's the fattest [ __ ]
you've ever done that's you know
stand outside of 7-eleven like literally
my car's right here I stood up and ate
it right outside cuz I used to live next
to a 7-eleven so I could just bring it
back I wanted hot
I want this sucks Spyro yeah it's
supposed to be gourmet pizza boy sucks
suppose we gourmet pizza where is it
it's in the shopping mall next to a
bruce mahler that branding Sbarro's
blend is here too but I'll still take
that over Papa John's just grabbing food
home like on the way home without even
asking and then you just be like hey I
got some extra stuff oh if you're hungry
go ahead and eat it and then this is why
that doesn't work and if no but that's
that's extra food for you cuz you're not
[Laughter]
gonna have a [ __ ] fight you shouldn't
be like I don't want your [ __ ]
leftovers you should have brought it
because you thought of me no no it's not
leftovers it's fresh it's to make it
more for him yeah I know but is what I'm
saying
I like leftovers if I haven't sorta
evening check I still have my soup just
get extra food well you said you don't
want to live now now I have your suit
yeah isn't it funny that we are all
bitching about what kind of pizza is
real and Italians are like that's not
even real pizza not if you were talking
about you know they have a committee
there's only two kinds of actual
authentic pizza there's a whole [ __ ]
group that debates on what is a real
[ __ ] pizza your [ __ ] authentic
[ __ ] so goddamn boring this [ __ ] is
delicious
any way you roll it i'ma tell you this
triad Italian pizza peace in Italy yeah
we have it small
Neapolitan behind it and alike is bomb
Americans do pizza better no no anything
even what the ingredients were too fresh
I'm like where's the [ __ ] chemicals
right I need the camp this [ __ ] basil
is overpowering everything okay is the
red oil the orange red oil if it's about
drinking of that [ __ ]
unidentified I know that's why I already
have to do [ __ ] map and suck the air
that's battery that's what I call Costco
Pizza I'm like can I get the oil and
they're like you mean the pizza I'll
make sure oil pie
[Music]